you think there's alien civilizations
all out there intelligent ones just far
in far on the distant Stars I
I hope so and I think we it's possible
may have many
Among Us right here
one and I go for the the why not in that
just to keep that that train of thought
open to the to learn and and and and and
consider
you know those existential questions I
think be arrogant not to there's so many
hundreds of billions of planets just in
our galaxy just in ours I can't imagine
there's not life out there
and um
but I suspect it's very different like
you said than we are and we have to have
a humility to open our eyes to how
different life could be
and if and when we cross it
unlike we've had a tendency to do when
we try to go with some Nation takeovers
um
I think
it would be R inherent
glitch
to go in
believing that any other life-form
civilization wants to take over
territories to go into it with thinking
that okay this is an opposition
I I mean I I think that's a human trait
of ours
and to consider that another life
form would have an interest
that more land or more territory
is good for them I think is I think it's
a shallow idea I don't think they're I
think of it more like you know when I
think of Heaven those considerations are
not
in in anyone's mind heart or
intent in the heaven that I think of you
know so in other civilization these
things I don't I mean I
I hope that if we would just see and
learn that would be
the natural side of welcoming it
wouldn't be a primate response to no I
have fire and you're coming over trying
to put it out or I have food and you're
trying to steal my food I don't I don't
think it would be
I think it's a shallow thought to think
that oh it's going to be about ownership
and we would be trespassing I think it
would be I don't think they're
would have a sense of borders as we do I
just hope we humans are smart enough to
detect and to see aliens
because because of how different they
are you know we don't we often have a
very narrow definition of what is
intelligence you know it's very possible
that trees are extremely intelligent if
we kind of zoom out at a different time
scale a different like just look at
stuff in a from a bigger perspective
that that's outside of being so
human-centric it's great
quote that someone told me this
astrophysicist told me this
how accurate is or not someone else can
argue the validity of what I might say
or not but I thought it really was a
prospective grabber for me like look see
the universe was created at midnight
humans came around at 11 59 and 36
seconds
I love little nowadays are that put that
frame like that make oh yeah the pale
blue dot there it is that perspective
something so relaxing and empowering
about that at the same time and humbling
but confidence boosting yeah you know
allows forgiveness allows ambition
um I just love the perspective of that
that picture to picture it that way in
our timeline